the Sahel is dry hot and vast so it's
difficult to govern and that provides
room for criminals who've trafficked
people weapons and drugs for years
still it was once safe enough to host
art and musical festivals and motorsport
events now much of it is a danger zone
the conflict that is more widely known
from the Sahel is the Boko Haram
insurgency in the lake Chad basin that's
in its tenth year now with the group and
its splinter factions still posing a
stubborn threat
further west another potent challenge
there's j'ni m which is linked with al
Qaeda and its rival is G s the local
affiliate of the so-called Islamic state
both are active in Mali Burkina Faso and
Nisha since 2016 attacks on civilians
and the military in these countries have
increased fivefold the UN says the
violence has left 5 million children in
the Sahel needing humanitarian aid
regional leaders and their international
partners have largely employed an armed
response which they plan to expand
France is leading the way but on the
ground not many support this former
colonial power in Mali there are 15,000
UN peacekeepers but with a limited scope
while they can put on a show of force
their mandate does not allow them to go
on the offensive and fight the armed
groups France has pushed for local
action and backed a multinational force
by the affected Nations is called g5
Sahel made up of troops from Mauritania
Mali Burkina Faso
Nisha and Chad but some donors have not
delivered on funding and others are not
convinced that this force is the
solution
Molly's government has struggled in the
battlefield and now it thinks a more
effective option might be to sit down
and talk things out with the extremist
leaders this despite opposition from
France but with limited military
strength and a feeble track record of
development the government appears
cornered and desperate much like its
neighbours
now Molly has been most affected by the
crisis and it's the country where it all
began in 2012 separatists and groups
linked to al-qaeda took over the
northern part of the country military
efforts to flush the mouse were
unsuccessful and now barely a decade
later armed groups are popping up in
other parts of Mali today much of the
conflict has been between the country's
two dominant ethnic groups the Muslim
Fulani and the Dogon thus anew refugee
camp on the outskirts of Mali's capital
Bamako around 200 hunts for about a
thousand people seeking safety from
attacks by the Dogon people in the east
of the country the refugees are fuller
herdsmen mostly Muslims like Zakaria
Diallo the hatred between the fula and
the Dogon peoples runs deep this
troubles acharya Diallo there was a
dispute in mandarin then they talked it
out but now the evil in our midst has
reached the village children their own
parents can no longer influence them the
young people have taken up arms also the
soldiers don't draw distinctions anymore
every single fool a child they see they
regard as a jihadi seeing Muslim
children as jihadis it's a widespread
attitude among soldiers and the society
here regarding an entire ethnic group as
the enemy it's hard to know why it
started on the Dogon side of town a
similar picture emerges they feel caught
in a spiral of violence after massacres
in their villages they too were
internally displaced and forced to flee
who knew telly lost everything she now
depends on handouts they killed ten
people in a single day the next day they
killed five on the third day they came
back and took our livestock cattle goats
everything in the name the people of
Mali are not just afraid for their lives
they're fed up with the weak economy a
government they see as corrupt teachers
who don't teach tens of thousands have
taken to the streets Muslim cleric
rotten wood nickel is a leading member
of the Opposition exactly what we've
denounced we can't be complacent about
the government leaders who got us into
this situation it has to stop the head
of state is mainly responsible Mahmoud
Eko is someone who may be able to help
the international community bring peace
to Mali
the French army and UN troops including
some from Germany's armed forces cannot
achieve it on their own at the table
with me now is Tommy or ladee PO he's
our resident expert on extremism on the
continent Tommy it's good to see you we
have just seen a report about the
situation of Mali we know that this is a
broader situation in the region that is
deteriorating how did we get here well
it's complex and Mali has had these
problems for a long time has had
security problems particularly in the
north there has been a disconnect a kind
of lack of understanding between the
government in Bamako and people in the
north of the country who where there's a
lot of inequality and there have been
groups there for many years who have
been clamoring for even autonomy but
those issues those socio-political
issues have now been overshadowed or
even overlap with these jihadist
problems we're seeing today because it's
volatile they've been arms and so jihadi
groups have seen it fit that this is the
kind of environment they can operate in
and that's why they have come in but the
problem is that unlike the groups
clamouring for autonomy you cannot sit
down or at least conventionally sit down
with jihadist groups and try and debate
and try and negotiate a way forward okay
Toby
these extremist groups they've they've
been growing stronger over the last
decade how have they been able to do
this well they have the space in in in
the north of Mali or at least across the
Sahel at many parts of the Sahel they
have the space they have the difficult
terrain they have the the problems where
people there's a lot of poverty and so
people are not necessarily against them
people are not necessarily for the
government that the residents of these
areas and so these jihadists can play on
those sentiments as well to get allies
within communities because they have a
presence everywhere you know even know
these places sometimes better than the
government does and so they're able to
operate I carry out hit-and-run attacks
against against the government against
the military and that way they can not
be found and so it's a very difficult
problem and and what they've then done
is that as they build their spread
they're also playing on for example
ethnic elements a you know dealing with
different ethnic groups and playing on
certain those hatreds we see between
certain groups and playing on that and
that then sort of gets them more support
and more more of a spread across this
region so we've seen this problem move
from Mali from the north of Mali go down
to the center central parts of Mali
across the border into Burkina Faso even
seeing the edge of Ivory Coast is being
attacked at the moment so that shows
just how delicate this is but having
said all of that right this is not just
an Africa problem if you look past the
Middle East if you look past what's
happening for example in Syria the Sahel
is the other major hotspot for terror
and the rest of the world is worried
that the main world powers are worried
and that's why for example if you look
at the peace peaking peacekeeping
mission in Mali that's the only one that
has attracted some of the world's top
powers you're talking about the Dutch
you're talking about the Germans who've
got massive contingents in there because
they want to use that as a way of get
intelligence for example we see the
French obviously have have got their
thousands of troops in the Sahel as well
the US has built a drone base in Asia
and is operating there so for example
recently we saw the French army kill a
top commander of al Qaeda in northern
Mali and they used American intelligence
to do that so we see that a lot of these
countries are worried that this is not
just a problem happening somewhere over
there far away but this is the problem
that can spiral and breed jihadis who
can come in and and be a threat on their
own Shores and so the world is worried
about this but this is the phenomenon
that's not just limited to the Sahel
we're seeing the rise of jihadism East
Africa the Horn of Africa we're seeing
even in southern Africa for example
south of Tanzania north of Mozambique
that area has also become a breeding
ground for jihadists and late you've
seen the the Mozambican jihadists going
on the rampage to a point wave and the
government they're shrugging and is
looking for outside help all right
Tomi illegible as ever our resident
expert on extremism on the continent
thank you for that thank you
[Music]
there are thousands of jihadi fighters
in the region and that brings us to the
question were asking today why are so
many young people being lured into these
militant groups in a moment we'll hear
from a former fighter about his personal
reasons but first have a listen to what
other people in Africa think I think
every team boils down to poverty they
are reportedly treated nicely by these
groups they use urban negligence the
Islamic notion of fire jeez it's
unemployment frustration Prentiss filled
in your responsibilities young people
feel that they are being left out they
are not being held we traced the and
ignorance education there's ignorant of
what the religion is all about because
of lack of understanding of what the
tournament of Islam is they don't know
the right in the adream because the
Bible said my people very because the
luck at wisdom I don't know I don't deny
of resources or on equal distribution of
the national cake extrajudicial killing
is the driver to take you to join this
malicious group is because of
unemployment in Kenya we have many
educated people an example exhibit a I
am a degree holder I have friends who
are doctors accountants who are
architects engineers who are unemployed
so the voices of people there now we go
to Mombasa Kenya where we miss a former
al-shabaab fighter who's now turned his
life around
we hear in his own words why he got
involved with the jihadists in the first
place
[ __ ] boo Fort nearly two years for
the terrorist group the former Christian
converted to Islam and went to Somalia
as a foreign fighter now he speaks out
for the first time about his
radicalization and how he got away from
al-shabaab for security reasons we need
to cover his real identity
poverty I come from it's a bit hush like
you see you have kids they don't go to
school you eat like one meal a day a
major issue that disturbing youth there
is unemployment lack of jobs drug
addiction you know stealing because they
I don't have jobs do you have to just
sit around wait for whatever will come a
terrorist recruiter promised Mohammed
$500 monthly to fight in Somalia he
accepted like many others he saw his
recruitment as a job the only way to
flee from poverty Mohammed was then
trained in Mombasa and sent to Somalia
you know when you start to shoot the
adrenaline comes into the body you start
to shoot even at the dog at the cart
even shoot at a woman there's one time I
remember there was a pregnant from a
woman the woman was dead I could see a
baby crying mommy mommy mommy mommy
ask myself is this right
Mohammed managed to escape al-shabaab
but he was wounded back in Kenya he was
given amnesty Mohammed is now supporting
the authorities that was the main
condition for his amnesty he now wants
others about the risks there is nothing
like holy war in the Quran find a good
share I will teach you and fast stay
away from people who you might think you
know a Muslim and they have money but
you don't know where the income comes
from but as long as poverty prevails
there will be young Africans who follow
the call of money I'm now joined by mu
taru mo moany Mukti he's from the West
African center of counter extremism and
he joins me from the Ghanaian capital
Accra welcome to DW news Africa we've
been hearing that poverty is one of the
main reasons young people are joining
terror groups do you think then that the
response to the crisis from governments
and other partners is too militaristic
and not addressing the real problem well
the problem power of terrorism in Africa
generally it's a product of or a
manifestation of the frustrations and
anguish of youth who have generally lost
faith in their states and the state's
ability to ensure they provide a
legitimate means of livelihood for them
you see a significant number of young
people who are unemployed you know
affected by several other challenges and
so poverty is one of the single biggest
fattest but it's not the whole story the
other factors that lead immediately
relate to dysfunctional societies people
who come from dysfunctional social
backgrounds you know complemented by
issues of poverty unemployment you know
inequality and
negative religious or political ideals
so poverty it's just one of them and so
to successfully counter terrorism or
this current wave of violent extremism
we need to ensure we have a holistic you
know comprehensive approach to dealing
with the drivers of radicalization and
violent extremism right so another thing
is for for the for the young fighters
who do return to society there is this
conversation about do we give them
amnesty or or do we just concentrate on
rehabilitating them and without
necessarily imposing punitive measures
ie prison where do you stand on that
well no any one particular case is a
same you know every single case is
unique and so for you to ensure I mean
to provide amnesty for in a so-called
repentant you know fighters we need to
analyze case by case basis there are
individuals we need to assess them to
determine what they would still pose a
threat to society when they are put back
into society you need to ensure you turn
thoroughly examine this in order to
avoid you know escalating the problems
even when you undergo amnesty programs
and so it has to be determined by
case-by-case depending on the profile of
the individual or individuals involved
but yes it's important to ensure that we
take people to amnesty rehabilitation
the radicalization program a kind of
program that helps revise or reverse the
outlook in life and ensure that we
practically enhance the ability to fend
for themselves in terms of learning
skills you know empowerment skills that
can you know provide livelihoods for
them when they get back into society so
what does it take to rehabilitate
somebody we often quote things like
reintegrating people into society but
from the work that you're doing which is
what you do on a daily what does it take
to actually rehabilitate somebody and
put them back into society you first
need to analyze the presence assess the
person's own vulnerabilities and the
fact that that led the person to that
point and once you're able to determine
was it as a reserve
of negative religious ideals versus as a
lot of poverty is as a result of a sense
of marginalization or inequality or
dysfunctional social factors in this
society once we were to determine that
you go back you know you went back was
to reverse that trend to ensure that he
is adequately put in the position where
he can positively participate in society
so this young guy 21 years we had to go
through his you know his past and assess
this factors we realized that through
the geological ization process he was
committed and willing to go back to
school we helped him go back to school
we paid for his schooling and everything
related to schooling two years after
that he graduated from school and is
currently working in journalism with the
media house that is what it means to get
somebody positively back into society to
ensure that they are positive
contributors to society the localization
is a very complex task that that
requires discipline to totally examine
each individual's keys to be able to get
them possibly back into society if you
don't get this right you are actually
undermining and putting this general
society at risk
okay that is muchas room una multa he's
from the West African center of counter
extremism thank you so much for your
insights and of course we continue to
hope that your work continues that more
people will be brought back into society
successfully thank you and as always we
would love to hear your thoughts on this
topic if you're watching this online
write in the comments section or you can
get in touch with me directly my twitter
handle is at mundo seven